В Україні настала чергова весна, а обіцяних президентом Зеленським "посадок" так і немає.
Час від часу відбуваються гучні затримання та оголошення підозр,
але в підсумку резонансні кримінальні справи в Україні закінчуються "пшиком".
Чому така ситуація не змінюється ані за Порошенка, ані за Зеленського?
Справи проти двох Геннадіїв: мера Одеси Труханова та Харкова Кернеса -
класичний приклад політичних торгів, стверджують антикорупційні активісти.
Геннадія Труханова звинувачували у розкраданні міського бюджету,
а Геннадія Кернеса та його охоронців у катуванні учасників Євромайдану в Харкові у 2014 році.
Було чимало правових підстав і фактів, але в підсумку нікого не посадили.
За словами політолога Володимира Фесенка, розслідування проти цих політиків то уповільнювали, то прискорювали, використовуючи як гачок.
Адже чинний тоді президент Петро Порошенко домовлявся про свою політичну підтримку в Одесі та Харкові відповідно.
Мовляв, такі собі подвійні стандарти в дії.
Як писали журналісти-розслідувачі, у Порошенка був негласний куратор судової системи Олександр Грановський
і досвід, як вирішувати проблеми в судах і домовлятися.
Зараз таких людей у команді Володимира Зеленського фактично немає, ситуація хаотична, вважають експерти,
і вплив президента на суди, не кажучи вже про уряд, практично зник.
Натомість збільшився вплив з боку різних політичних сил, які розхитують ситуацію,
і конфлікт з Конституційним судом, який скасував статтю про незаконне збагачення - один з найяскравіших прикладів.
Українські президенти завжди намагалися використовувати неофіційні методи впливу на суди.
Порівняно з попередниками у Зеленського таких інструментів найменше.
З одного боку, це плюс - незалежність судової системи.
Але в українських реаліях цей принцип незалежності судів працює на збереження нинішньої корумпованої судової системи.
За словами опитаних DW експертів, у 2000-их почали формуватися картелі з представників МВС, прокуратури та судів.
Якщо раніше брали гроші за неправосудний вирок, коли людина справді була винна і мала б сісти за ґрати,
то потім потрібно було платити і за ту ситуацію, коли ти абсолютно правий.
Суди стали фактично комерційними конторами, які заробляли на своїй діяльності.
За оцінками розслідувачів, одне з найбільших мафіозних угруповань - навколо Окружного адміністративного суду Києва.
Його голову Павла Вовка та інших суддів звинувачують у створенні злочинної організації та захопленні влади.
Але ця справа блокується його ж корумпованими колегами.
За словами юристки Центру протидії корупції Тетяни Шевчук, Вовка покриває Вища рада правосуддя, яка не дає дозволу на його арешт.
В нього мандат судді і відповідно спеціальна процедура відповідальності,
тому іншим органам мало що можна зробити, а вся судова система заточена, щоб покривати один одного.
Прикриваючись незалежністю судової гілки влади, у судах панує свавілля і корупція та гальмується розвиток резонансних справ.
Справи Бахматюка, Микитася, Татарова, Приватбанку, Роттердам+ та інші.
НАБУ, за оцінками експертів, справді проводить розслідування і намагається щось зробити,
але решта правоохоронної системи чинить цьому опір.
Крім того, багато гучних справ розслідуються поліцією та ДБР під процесуальним керівництвом Офісу генпрокурора.
А ці органи мають певну слабкість до впливу ззовні.
За словами виконавчого директора "Трансперенсі Інтернешнл Україна" Андрія Боровика,
приміром, щодо Кернеса навряд чи було бажання притягнути його до відповідальності,
а справу Татарова зараз намагаються "поховати",  змінюючи орган досудового розслідування та кваліфікацію злочинів,
щоб вивести цю справу з виключної підслідності НАБУ.
Заступника керівника Офісу президента Олега Татарова звинувачують у причетності до фальсифікації експертизи Укрбуду.
Експерти також відзначають, що в Україні склалася коаліція різноманітних політичних сил,
причому від ОПЗЖ до "Європейської солідарності" -  проти антикорупційного законодавства.
Бо всі вони опинилися під загрозою притягнення до відповідальності
й спільно затягували створення Вищого антикорупційного суду та інших реформ.
Попри брак політичної волі та перешкоджання запуску Вищого антикорупційного суду він таки запрацював.
За 18 місяців роботи є доволі суттєві результати - понад 60 вироків, і далі має бути ще більше.
Раніше прокуратура була змушена спрямовувати корупційні справи у нереформовані суди загальної юрисдикції.
Були справи, де по півтора року не відбувалося підготовчого засідання.
Перший вирок - за обвинуваченням колишньої судді - Антикорсуд розглянув за 42 дні.
Раніше ця справа перебувала в інших судах 567 днів.
Експерти та оглядачі сподіваються, що ця антикорупційна статистика нарешті почне покращуватись
і судитимуть не лише виконавців, а й організаторів.
Антикорсуд поки ще себе не заплямував і вважається серед багатьох експертів незалежним органом.
І все ж, потрібно реформувати та очистити усю судову систему.
Щоправда, як зробити це швидко та у правовому полі, єдиного бачення поки немає.